vous avez perdu l'odorat le goût mais il
vous reste la beauté la gentillesse le
talent
et je suis sérieux et
les cordes vocales et la voix
vous pouvez dire non mais en général
ceux qui disent non ce sont ceux qui
chantent en playback je n'ai rien
préparé mais je vais vous faire un petit
air d'opéra
[Musique]
vous êtes
pour le troisième sonate
[Musique]
heureusement que le public est un peu
moins jeune que le chroniqueur
donc il risque de connaître cette séance
ça peut aider alors c'est parti
j'irai bien faire un tour du côté de
chez soi revint mon premier amour qui me
donnait rendez-vous
sous le Sean et il se laissait
t'embrasser sur la joue je ne voudrais
pas refaire le chemin alors et pourtant
j'étais riche pour vivre seul
le temps du bonheur
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir
été avec nous